now to the devastation caused by
Hurricane Fiona which is now a category
4 storm it's headed towards Bermuda
after slamming the Turks and Caicos with
winds up to 125 miles an hour the storm
also forced more than 12 000 people from
their homes in the Dominican Republic
due to flooding and then Puerto Rico
more than a million people are still
without power after Monday's landfall
our lead National correspondent David
begno is there David good morning
good morning my friend for the third
straight day Puerto Ricans are waking up
with no power now the governor made a
bold prediction yesterday he said David
I think we're going to get the power on
as soon as tomorrow that would be today
they're going to hold him accountable to
people who live here here's what we've
seen over the last 24 hours
foreign
to lahas that's a town on the
southwestern side of Puerto Rico right
near where hurricane Fiona made landfall
how long have you lived here 25 years in
the Hills above law house we met Olga
Vega right outside her home
he and her daughter rode out the storm
in the bathroom part of her tin roof was
ripped off but her problems don't end
with the hurricane it's very dangerous
here
this is what's because of the tremors
oh because of the earthquake she
reminded us that this area has been
dealing with small earthquakes for the
last two years how are you doing
emotionally
I am beginning to feel weak I have
nothing I don't have clean coats and
everything is out of place
no water no power no room no power and
she is not alone the vast majority of
Puerto Ricans are still without power
roughly half don't have water is there
any more flooding in lahas no it was the
mayor of law house Jason Martinez who
took us around saying people weren't
waiting on the government to show up
they were helping each other clean up
quickly Martinez is a former electric
lineman who helped to restore power
after Hurricane Maria five years ago he
made this prediction now maybe two
months to be
ready to to get night again oh you think
it'll take two months
[Music]
from lahas we flew East over the
municipality of jalco and saw part of
what one expert called the worst hit to
Puerto Rico's agriculture industry in 20
years fields of plantains bananas dairy
products all underwater and ruined then
we landed in Salinas where Puerto Rico's
Governor Pedro Pierre luisi had just
arrived my assessment is that this
substantial majority of the customers
will get their power back
by the end of the day tomorrow really
yeah
and that would be today so we'll see all
right so that's what's happening now
coming up at 7 30 another major story
here on the island patients doctors
researchers will all tell you the Health
Care System here on the island is
collapsing it's a story we've been
working on for the last two weeks you
won't want to miss it we'll see you
again at 7 30. Tony
David bagner for us in Puerto Rico will
go back to him shortly David for now
thank you very much